hello everyone and welcome to the last
day of the super United Blitz tournament
currently being played in Zagreb Croatia
a story about no videos up until now the
tournament is already over but I was
actually at the tournament I visited the
playing venue and I I had the pleasure
of meeting some of the players so I
managed to get my board signed uh and
I've uh you know talked to some of the
players I've talked to a lot of people
I've talked to Peter leko I've talked to
alirez's Father I've talked uh well I
I've met a lot of you you guys were also
there as fans so it was a great
experience for me and
um yeah this is the board that I got
signed unfortunately I didn't get all of
the signatures I did get some of them uh
and I did also get a Lego's signature on
the board even though uh he's not
playing in the tournament but it's
actually my grandfather's board who
passed away some 10 years ago and
um uh he he won the board in a
tournament in Vikings like in eight in
1986 so I thought it would uh you know
uh commemorate the board quite well if I
get get it signed by these great players
and I'm sure my Grandpa would be very
happy about that but I came to later I
completely forgot that always on the
final day of the tournament the rounds
started an hour earlier so I was uh
pretty sure the the round start at uh 3
P.M they started at 2 p.m so by the time
that I arrived the players were already
going into the playing Hall and well
like I said I've managed to only to
catch some of them uh here you can see
I've caught Magnus uh just as I arrived
in the in the playing Hall uh he I think
he like came back from jogging I think
he went straight from jogging into
playing chess so I managed to get a
board signed by Magnus also I managed to
get it signed by Nepal here uh he was
also uh going to the game a bit earlier
not not waiting like for the final
second and also uh this is a Leonard
Otis he is the main behind pretty much
all the photos you will see on this
channel as he covers pretty much all all
the tournaments so there you have it if
you have a sea Leonard everywhere
anywhere you know just you know buy him
a beer as he is truly a great warrior so
that being said let's check out the game
so this is only one of the games I'm
sure you guys already know Magnus won
the tournament he was uh incredible uh
yesterday he won uh all the games he
went nine out of nine and he said that
it will probably never happen again and
of course he started the the the second
day of the Blitz by drawing his game
against Fabiano Cortana but this is a
game against Nepal really a weird one as
it often is so let's uh check it out
nepo has the white pieces and he opens
with Pawn to B3 he goes for the nimsel
Larson attack and here uh well
principled would be to grab the full
center with a move like D5 or E5 but
instead we have Pawn to G6 sorry about
that with Bishop to B2 uh grabbing the
full diagonal here going after the rook
and Knight to F6 we have Pawn to E4 and
now Pawn to D6 interestingly and the Y
Magnus went for this G6 line I believe
because Magnus already played this
against the animation they played it in
the Saint Louis Blitz tournament in 2020
and the Nepal defeated Carlson in this
line but in that game Magnus played C5
here he goes for Pawn to B6 uh and okay
Nepal was spawned F4 and Bishop to G7 uh
someone asked me on Twitter if I was
able to get uh anand's signature on the
board I was not able to get it as he was
also already in the playing Hall but
when he saw me he did smile at me and
wave at me so at least that you know
it's not not as great as a signature but
I was very happy that he did that and
also I didn't want to disturb any of the
players do you know in between games
um uh Duda finished his round one game
extremely quickly so I was able to get
his signature and also uh the Fabiano as
I was in the sort of the the the VIP
area I was near the players and whenever
they finished their rounds they would
they would come out and then they were
just you know enjoy the other games uh I
was uh uh also there but I didn't want
to annoy them to sign my board there
except I did annoy Fabiano uh because he
finished his game very early he won the
game very nicely and he was very very
happy you know just talking to everyone
so I was like hello he you know he waved
at me and then uh he he also decided to
sign the board but other than that I
really didn't annoy anyone uh but okay
Bishop to G7 we have Knight to have
three castles and now Pawn to D3 we have
Pawn to E5 and now F characters on E5
uh Point behind the the temporary Pawn
sacrifice is of course Knight to G4 by
Magnus uh where you cannot continue
capturing further as the bishop on B2 is
hanging so here we have Knight beat
Knight beta D2 and it is now already as
of move eight that we have a completely
new game uh we have Knight to C6 by
Magnus now getting ready to capture back
on E5 as you have four pieces attacking
it well three pieces and a pawn and now
just Queen to E2 continuing development
preparing the castle Queen side and the
well Magnus could perhaps postpone
castling with some like a five or Bishop
to H6 he just captures back Knight G
captures on E5 Pawn to D4 now castling
here would be a bit more precise but the
D4 looks like such a principled idea uh
grabbing the full Center and it will of
course if Magnus trades then uh you just
remain with a with a strong Center the
problem is your queen and king are still
beautifully aligned on the E file and
this could lead to problems Knight
captures on F3 by Magnus Knight captures
on F3 and now Rook to E8 and now you
can't move both the queen and the King
into one move so here of course it's
better to hide the king and Nepal
castles Queen side but now Bishop to F5
by Magnus now how do you defend here
well best would be to play something
like Knight to D2 but still then you
play Bishop capture Sunny fortnite
captures and D5 and it's not pleasant
for white not at all you have to move
the king at some point Rook captures an
E4 okay Queen F2 uh you have sufficient
defense of the D4 pawn and the game
continues so this is probably
at best for nepo but instead he played
Ponte E5 he wanted to keep everything
and now just the D characters on E5 and
again the captors is what you should
play he played Knight Caps or he played
Knight captures on E5 Magnus captured
back with the Knight and now D captures
on E5 but now it's a little bit
different the queen to G5 comes with
check King to B1 and now I move you uh
would think impossible Bishop captures
on E5 how is this even a move as uh well
you're defending the five square twice
so Bishop captures an E5 and it seems
great because you cannot play F6 just
Queen to C4 check so here's what Magnus
finds Rook captures on E5 and now you
cannot capture back if you capture back
then Bishop captures and see if you
check picks up the queen on E5 so here
after Rook captures an E5 nipple moves
the queen queen to C4 and now Rook to d8
the only correct way to utilize your
advantage the rook and D1 is undefended
the Rooks are still disconnected so how
do you defend well Bishop the D3 is the
only way but even this uh doesn't seem
like it's gonna help white all that much
point is that after Bishop captures Rook
captures you're gonna trade even further
Rook captures Queen captures they know
just Queen captures and G2 and you're up
uh two pawns uh chances are white is
down too much material to defend this
you don't have time for something like
checking captures as The Rook on H1 is
hanging and once The Rook moves you will
just offer a queen trade I mean maybe
it's uh you know in in some perfect
scenario maybe you can defend this but
very unlikely in a Blitz game no way so
I have to Rook that the eight nipple
tried Bishop to E2 to avoid all of the
trades and still connect the Rooks but
now again the position is completely
winning but you have to figure out the
correct idea feel free to pause the
video and win the game for Magnus while
I give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh a beautiful move and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Pawn to B5 yes sometimes it is Pawn to
B5 it's not a respawn to B4 but here
there's not much to be done because the
bishop here uh cannot be defended if you
move the queen Rook captures an EQ is
coming so the only move you can play is
Queen captures on C7 attack the rook and
d8 point being now that of course if
Rook captures and D1 the bishop can
capture and now the bishop is no longer
hanging however Magnus finds the
strongest reply Rook to C8 and he was in
this position and move 20 that
janiponishu resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here ah
it's uh it's a it is just a you know a
complete Massacre 20 moves and uh well
yeah once you move of course you will
start to losing material and that's it
if Queen to D6 okay maybe you try
something even Rook captures an E2 you
pick up the bishop first and now you
will start uh capturing on C2 there is a
there is no way to defend this uh very
nicely done by Magnus not just winning
this game this is only one of the games
that he won uh he won many of them as he
won the tournament as well here are the
final standings of the grand chess tour
uh so Magnus wins it uh here uh current
he wins the tournament uh and these are
the grand Chester points although you
can see that Magnus is a wild card so he
doesn't get any Grand Chester points but
for those who are actually playing in
the grand Chester not just for this
tournament uh nepo with 10 points
already with eight points Fabiano Corona
with seven and upward with five uh in
the young sister of Duda with three and
a half and the as you can see uh quite a
lot of money it has been one Magnus says
the wild card has won forty thousand
dollars nipple Thirty now it is at 25
Fabiano's 15 and so on and so on and uh
you know uh quite uh quite a pleasant
experience for everyone and I imagine
not for Constantine and also not not
maybe for uh even Charice Anand also uh
he he played incredible chess he
dominated in the Rapids uh and then he
slowed down in in the blitz but I mean
what are you gonna do uh so yeah uh
that's uh you know a little bit of
photos a little bit of uh info about the
tournament a little bit of uh standings
if any of you guys have taken a lot of
photos with with fans there if you guys
um you know uh have them do send them to
me I can also share them with everyone
so you know that would also be uh very
nice uh but yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it if I haven't uh seen
any of the games I I did the watch games
in the lobby with some of the players
and while I did enjoy them I didn't
really uh see many of them uh so if you
have any of your favorites uh do hashtag
suggestion and I will uh take a look but
now we are going to tend to some other
events that are happening in the Chess
World uh so yeah once again really hope
you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank James Eugene Cashman John Austin
Paul Miller Brad Roth and uh Michael
Marshall uh for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chat world thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day